if the banks don't play ball on savings
rates what do you think
no I think that they should just be
getting on and making sure they pass
that on to Savers I think there is
agreement right across the board that's
what needs to happen and it's time for
action
um okay so windfall tax though or not
no we've set out plans around how we
would have a whimple tax in the oil and
gas companies we've got no further plans
of anything anything of that description
I do just think it's a case of the banks
taking action and making sure they're
passing on those interest rates to save
us it's incredibly important you know
when mortgage rates goes up when
mortgage rates go up they're all too
Keen to pass that on where it comes to
the interest rate but not for Savers and
I think that's a fundamental issue that
really does need addressing and I would
say there was agreement across
Parliament that that needs to happen but
the government really need to put them
under pressure to do it so what would
you do to make them do it then if you
were in power
I think there is a lot The Government
Can Do where it comes to the regulator
but also the levers that they have and
getting the banks in telling them what's
expected of them what we would expect
for them to be doing and putting that
pressure on and you know I think it is
important that happens as I say I think
there is widespread agreement that needs
to be the case
um and we back the government up on on
measures to make that happen
so what you say appealing to their
better nature do you think they've got
one
yeah I think the regulator has
um has a role to play as well but
actually governments of all Persuasions
have powers in terms of the influence
and the levers that they can use and the
influence they can exert to make change
happen it's not always just about
legislation in Parliament it's about the
wider influence that you can bring to
bear on decision making
okay talk to me about education reforms
smashing the class ceiling is what your
leader is going to be talking about
today tell us more are you going to
achieve that
so today here in Kent Kia Stormer is
making a speech about how we transform
life chances how we make sure that your
barrier is no background to getting on
in life and that we do break down those
barriers that class ceiling that holds
that holds back too many of our children
and young people you know what we tell
our kids is that if you work hard you'll
get on in life but increasingly that
isn't the case so where today is setting
out a long-term plan Labor's mission on
opportunity to make sure that all of our
children and young people get the chance
to succeed so from the early years
making sure we're getting a really
strong foundation for our children high
in Rising standards in our schools and
then when young people move on Beyond
school that they get really great
opportunities I think our country's best
days can and do lie ahead of us but we
need a government with really radical
change to deliver that to make it happen
and to break down those barriers that
all too often still exist so give me
some examples of how you do that
well one of the big ways that we know we
change lives is through having a really
great education system and part of that
is around teaching quality the biggest
impact that you can make in terms of
outcomes for children is the quality of
teaching within a school that's why I've
set out plans for how we retain more
teachers in our classrooms how we have
more teachers coming into teaching at a
point at which we're facing a really big
Recruitment and Retention challenge so
that's about raising the status of
teaching about all teachers having
qualified teacher status and about
additional incentive payments when
they've completed their first two years
in the job at the moment so many parents
will know that the teachers who are
coming through are not necessarily
always the expert teachers in their
field because we've got that really
really big shortage at the moment and
it's also about young people and our
children having a really strong
Foundation at the start of their lives
in the early years that's why I want to
drive up standards in early years
education as well as in our schools as
well so much about what happens in
education transforms lives we need to do
much more as a country to give
opportunities to all of our children
I suppose teachers would say is paying
teachers properly we were hearing about
teachers using food banks to get by we
had the veterans Minister
um Johnny Mercer on the program earlier
on in the week he was saying that it's a
choice to use a Food Bank certainly when
it came to the armed services
um what do you think
I don't think use of a food bank is a
choice that anyone wants to make and I
know when I've spoken to people in my
community in Sunderland who've been
using food banks they often find it
incredibly demeaning that I mean they
shouldn't because it's through no fault
of their own but they don't want to be
reduced to handouts and from charity I
mean the people that work in our food
banks and volunteer are absolutely
amazing and they're doing all they can
but I don't want to be in a society
where people who do the right thing who
work hard have to depend on the charity
and Goodwill of strangers in order to
get on and sadly we've seen a massive
growth in the number of food banks right
across our country partly because wages
haven't been keeping up because we
haven't had growth over these last 13
years and I do think it is shameful that
in modern Britain that's the State of
Affairs that we've got to and we you
know we need to see that shift across
society and yes of course I want to make
sure that everyone is properly supported
and properly rewarded when they're doing
their work
okay just before I let you go um let's
talk briefly about AI something that
we're talking about a lot on Sky News
um today do you think AI could do your
job
I don't know about that I think AI does
have the potential to open up
opportunities in the education field
more widely I think there are
opportunities there as well as the
potential for risks that we need to
mitigate against but I think things are
moving very fast and certainly when I've
spoken to to experts in the field who
are working in this day-to-day they say
the pace of change even for them is
incredibly rapid and I think there is a
rule for government in making sure that
further development and change is
properly regulated and that we're making
sure there aren't unintended consequence
from what could be you know really
transformational in many ways in terms
of delivery of Public Services
yeah but you're not here with me this
morning how do I know it's really you
well I would say that's part of the
challenge actually because in the
absence of Regulation
um you know I can I can ask you can ask
me some questions that only I could
answer if you really want some proof but
I think that is the the challenge around
regulation around making sure that what
we are seeing uh we can be absolutely
confident of its Providence and and
there have been examples I know more
recently where where there have been
kind of you know deep fake technology
used to to misrepresent so it's a
challenge for governments across the
world um but I do think we need to see
working with our partners
internationally to get kind of clear
regulation about how we do use this new
technology which I think has amazing
potential but risks alongside it too
what was the name of your first pet
foreign
it's good to talk to you thanks very
much indeed for joining us thanks a lot